hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer folge die das ein
spiel was er zweideutig ist und sehr
sexuell geprägt und wir müssen aufgaben
erfüllen und das machen wir jetzt das
ist nämlich mit spots dieses wir sind
der wir haben gar keine beine
radevormwald mein gott ich kann ja
richtig schnell kann ich springe ich
kann auch springen verdammte scheiße
jährigen skaterpark herumlaufen ich kann
ich könnte meine bank köpfen wow
wir müssen dem spielaufträge vermisste
spots erfüllen und was ist denn die kann
ich da irgendwie rein oder so hier vorne
haben wir mordes java ok starbucks und
was das hier ist keine ahnung ich glaube
ich kann hier mit nahezu nichts
interagieren kann ich apatows ntd
news.com ist okay das heißt wir es okay
wenn sie das unbedingt will
ach das ist ja so zweideutig jazz
englisch und heißt einmal brust
andererseits allerdings auch history
have captured okay das heißt wir müssen
die kiste wahrscheinlich zu ihr dahin
bringen wo junge dauert das lange man
die letzten fucking meter dick ist
wenn sie reckmann meint sie
wahrscheinlich
was heißt der nummer reck auf englisch
glaube reckhaus gestell deswegen schauen
wir mal ob wir genau hier vorne und
jetzt können wir das gestell hier
hinsetzen und danke mit partys mal los
mit der nächsten aufgabe wie das aber
ähnlich will sondern sie meint
wahrscheinlich safe dieser melonen hier
dann was soll ich machen hier wird so
dahin und jetzt die andere nehmen wir
jetzt auch mal eben mit dir du bist
meine form und jetzt packen wir die auch
hier hinunter
was für ein schock wieso bewegt sich
diese fakih melone melone
wir hatten das gespräch schon mal user
melden was bildet diese melone sich
einfach davon zu laufen
hier ist nicht nur ein gefälle oder so
ich sage euch freunde am ende des videos
ist diese melone ganz weiter hinten ach
so erfreuen wie heute wenn ihr das video
seht wahrscheinlich ist der neunzehnte
märz und morgen am 20 märz gibt es 20
prozent auf alle artikel im juca short
ich wollte das nur eben sagen weil das
ist doch nachträgliches
geburtstagsgeschenk ich wurde ja vor
circa einem monat 20 jahre alt deswegen
nicht nachkommen haben wir 20 prozent
raus weil sich einige über die teuren
preise beschwert haben obwohl ich gar
nicht mal von den preisen von revier
opels ins gop cetera anfangen will wir
haben recht teure preise weil die sachen
halt qualitativ die besten sind dies in
youtube deutschland gibt allerdings habe
ich mir gedacht so als nachträgliches
geburtstagsgeschenk 20 prozent auf alle
sachen im lukas shop daher blende ich
euch jetzt mal ganz kurz ein foto einer
mission einfach weil rabattcode luca 20
eingeben und dann macht das einfach
morgen das geht von heute nacht 0 uhr
bis morgen 8 0 uhr und dann könnt ihr 20
prozent kriegen jetzt weiter mit mit
video wird zocken jetzt weiter wachse
was also jobs heißt tippen
was könnte sie wohl meinen job ich
glaube ich außerdem behälter dh wir
können da fragt das hab ich gar nicht
umgeschmissen wo er kenne erklärte sich
ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung wo ich
das jetzt irgendwie saubermachen das
becken sie tatsächlich nicht so sauber
aus ok dann packe ich das jetzt mal hier
dj jetzt nehme ich noch schnell den
anderen job mit sack und denen kleinen
wir jetzt auch eben schnell hier hinten
in diesem komischen wasserausfluss hier
so den druck weil es eben hier jetzt
nehmen wir den wieder mit und den return
ich jetzt ebenfalls zu dem choral sodass
sie ist gelaufen
sie läuft tatsächlich als wäre sie ein
model hey du stehst leicht schief was
soll ich polieren natürlich meint die
wahrscheinlich dieses ding hier deswegen
an
mir wird dass sie tatsächlich ein
bisschen zu sexuell gerade 8 ich kann
hier im oder das hat doch nichts drunter
mein gott kann ich das irgendwie auch
mitnehmen hier ist auch nichts drunter
wenn ich hier wieder grafe sieht man
dass hier auch ein kilo
und zwar schon bei ist plötzlich mit
spots etwas tut was zum heiligen figge
spots dein kopf ist komplett am arsch
altar ihr könnt mir vielleicht hat mein
finanz irgendwie geist ist was tut sie
denn da hat laut händlern sind das nicht
irgendwie scheinwerfer sind
wahrscheinlich irgendwie also ich denke
natürlich wieder dass die die man
wahrscheinlich das auto oder den
headlines checken
let's take a closer look at leitzins von
den new sportscar ich will eigentlich
gar keine neue aufgabe von mir bekommen
ein paar sekunden später konnte ich soll
fotos von mir spaß machen und schaut sie
euch an kann sogar sagen sie soll etwas
anderes und dann kann ich auch glaube
ich mitteilen kann ich die kamera auf
theoretisch
könnte ich mir eigentlich schon die
ganze zeit jetzt anschauen wir haben als
kameraposition auch noch diese hier und
wir haben auch noch und könnte ich mir
tatsächlich auch ganz lange zeit
anschauen wer hätte es gedacht wir haben
natürlich auch noch diese
kameraperspektive logik des malens der
immer noch die animation dass sie
schnell sprinten esposto sprint ist in
der luft das sieht auf jeden fall sehr
natürlich aus wir haben auch noch das
die ganze mal nur steht dann
ich glaube dieses videos ab 18 uhr
tamara fucking volk was haben wir denn
jetzt hier verkaufen aber wir haben auch
noch dass sie wieder ganz normal liegen
dass sie sich auf den rücken legt dass
sie und dann ich freunde ich beende das
video an dieser stelle das ganze hat
tatsächlich spaß gemacht ich mag ja
solche bescheuerten spiele aber dass ich
mir am ende irgendwie was angucken muss
wo sie